welcome to this video playing dbv EBV or
DB foul but probably dbv from the US so
the names oh yeah someone requested I
should play the Dutch defense more yeah
maybe I will why not maybe I get the
hook no variation here the variation
that i'm featuring in my book this
should be three okay check yeah this is
blacks idea he's trading off him his
some dark square to bishop and then puts
all the points on dark squares so you
enjoy some very healthy structure if I
if it's a bit a bit uncommon play low
though what can play that it's not dumb
not totally bad or anything okay let's
see here f for that sets a very sharp
move Yahoo piayed or Queenie seven
I is probably going to play a for next
Bishop maybe close Bishop d7 c6 maybe
I'm expecting you for him maybe if I was
interesting the idea could be to take
and play Bishop f4 trying to activate
the dark squared Bishop I also might
play an e for myself yeah he's going for
it maybe I should play 97 I might play a
50
okay I'm taking and playing 97 I can
play if I hmm that was not good that
wasn't good he can play five attacking
age 70 ah yeah but I don't really have a
big alternative now I could have played
97 instead of taking yeah yeah of course
hmm pour moi
I idiotic here yes I really I saw this
too late v5 I really saw into later this
this is probably too much too much of an
attack
community to Bishop h6 may be playing it
in a very straightforward fashion
unbelievable and I simply cannot take on
a phone and I don't need you I mean
there are some ways to play instead of
that
yeah e6 one of the one of the very
dangerous looking at Tech ingles check
at least I'm at least I don't have much
to think about I mostly don't have many
moves or much much choice that's said
like that
I die I don't see yet how he winds but
there probably is something try to be
quick so at least I'm not term and I'm
not losing on time as well should be six
coming 'if I've Bishop takes h6 our
butter I don't know what else I should
do and I'm not sure that I'm let this
lose this Bishop h6 takes Queen takes
King g8 how am I losing after that
rookie three or something but I have
Queen g7 maybe this is ok then so Queen
d3 maybe may be on the horizon night
night muah
23 23 but queen bee three are here
Knight f6 I don't know I really don't
know that's like dodging bullets in this
position
Knight f6 f6 I I thought I with Bishop
takes maybe just Bishop takes Bishop
takes Queen d7 maybe to try to to hang
on this is no mate Quinn g6 maybe then I
came at least I'm not directly
checkmated check check wow I'm slaw
office still alive time warning Claude
run garmin did after this game hahaha
yeah I really don't want to win on time
after it was totally busted and i'm
still I'm so lost ya still have at least
his clarity worse what a bad mistake I
made in the opening this is this is all
okay this is okay of course yeah I can
take on f4 maybe yeah this is what he's
suggesting ruki aid it's okay for me
yeah yeah it's clear but I wanted to I
wanted to keep the tension before I must
improve here this is a terrible mistake
probably man night age 5 the computer
wants to do this still with an okay
position but
this is not what I wanted I should after
you for I should just play this him
intending Bishop c6 after the captcha I
go here and I'm perfectly okay he can
try this but then i have Bishop c6 and I
always have this pressure against you
for this is no terrible if the right
stockfish yes on minus 0.6 or 0.5 um
yeah yeah I just this is his move here
me I just double him I'm not going to
get going to get checkmate at ens
position like its blackest is more
comfortable here because of the
excellent structure if I get in the
right piece traits i can i can try to
try to win this but it's a it's not easy
to do it's not probably in all
likelihood may be here g5 could be could
be interesting yeah white white is worse
IAM his bishops don't do much those
pawns will be weaknesses it's not that
this is not a false line he's putting
we're just playing a game within the
game in a way he put it he put some
moves on the board as well it is
sometimes questionable if why does let's
say swapping everything on f6 if black
can really win because the position is
so closed but if every if anybody is
better it's it's clearly black who can
try something maybe with the draw at the
end but ok but let's let's check the
game where i was i was in this terrible
shape I cannot take this is this is
totally off check man ok my king
I'm just I'm just in terrible shape e
six takes check probably many ways to
put me away Bishop see towards got a
plate that here Queen d3 exhibition be
527 Queen g6 Queen g6 is winning out I
suspected that I wanted to play the
problem is this is this is crushing and
doped and then I have no move I have
absolutely no move here this is this is
curtains totally over check checkmate
I'm just I'm just dead here was I was
very very lucky dad didn't get
checkmated and this I can continue to
play i mean it's it's just the upon that
I'm down but yeah it was a total loss of
course okay thanks for watching